[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Поділля,
Бакота]
Це місто було.
Місто, яке було, за даними археологів,
третиною тодішнього Києва.
І воно тоді й виросло в цій долині,
в придністровській, на лівому березі завдяки
[Тарас Горбняк
Краєзнавець]
його унікальному розташуванню.
Це наявність води, по-друге, родючі землі,
по-третє, захищеність від вітрів
ну, і в крайньому разі, Дністер,
та перетинання торгівельних шляхів:
воно могло іти як по річці Дністер,
так і впоперек річки.
Були й піші, й водні шляхи.
Моє прізвище Горбняк,
вся моя родина жила на горбі,
от тому ми і Горбняки.
Село було прикордонним,
на лівому березі Дністра.
Це був 22 роки кордон з Румунією.
Ви знаєте, то сьогодні нам смішно,
то такі умови проживання,
що сьогодні навіть уявити...
Купатися не можна, ловити рибу теж,
пасти корови не можна,
у кожному селі — застава.
Навпроти кожного села —
мур в два метри.
Співати не можна, свистати не можна,
в яскравому ходити також.
Перша постанова Ради Міністрів у Москві,
яку підписав ще Косигін,
звучала так: на Дністрі має бути збудовано
каскад гідроелектростанцій.
Нам говорили про три,
тільки ми не уявляли, що воно таке,
бо тоді навіть що таке гідроекологічні,
ніхто навіть взагалі не міг уявити,
що це таке є.
16 000 гектарів найродючіших земель,
100 гектарів лісу.
Ніхто не підраховував,
скільки садів виноградників,
і 28 зниклих сіл — оце його ціна.
Ціна цього найкращого місця,
яке сьогодні має 204 км водосховища.
Ну а це найбільше —
воно має 1590 гектарів, така заплава.
Оце та ціна, яку люди заплатили,
ті, які жили в цих долинах,
бо колись же вони раділи,
що вода їх годувала.
Ну там, де ви купалися, колись був мій город,
тільки це на 25 метрів нижче.
Вісім років відбувалось переселення, планове.
Шість років ішло заповнення водою.
Тобто це не один день, і не просто так:
сказали сьогодні,
а завтра тебе вже немає.
— Це насправді?
— Це насправді так.
Будували хати, купували хати,
стареньким давала держава.
І це все тривало вісім років.
Бо ж були старенькі, які не могли.
Держава компенсовувала.
Цих компенсації вистачило
десь на 30-40 % від майбутніх витрат.
Але умова переселення була для людей,
які жили тут, насправді трішки жорсткувата:
тобі 20% не додавали компенсації,
які тобі держава вертала,
для того, щоб ти сам зруйнував свою хату,
вирубав дерева у своєму садку, або фактично ти знищував те родинне гніздо своїми руками,
яке твої батьки, діди і сам надбав.
І тому я один із тих, хто руйнував свою хату,
бо в іншому разі ти недоотримаєш
800, 1000 там чи 700 карбованців —
тоді треба було рік і більше
працювати на цю зарплату.
Знаєте, що таке самому зруйнувати свою хату?
Це були умови переселення.
Що таке залишити ту долину, яка для людей була...
Взагалі не тільки вони до неї прикипіли,
а вони вклали все своє туди.
І садок, і хату збудував,
і мав можливість, наприклад,
для інших щось своє зробити.
І раптом настає момент,
що ти це все не тільки сам зруйнував,
а й залишаєш його, цю землю.
Печери, в які ми з вами зайдемо,
мають в собі історію майже 4000 років.
Колись ще кременем видовблені печери
насамперед 3000 років слугували
для поклоніння природі:
сонцю, воді, вітру, небу, вогню і так далі.
Оце найдовша і найменш ще вивчена його історія.
Крім цих печер, ще знайшли стопу,
вибиту на камені.
Стопу людини, що трактується,
як дохристиянський символ
«шлях людини у потойбічний світ».
[Також знайшли] кам'яні статуї,
багато жертовників, кам'яні ідоли
і все це датується
від 1750 до 2000 років до нашої ери.
Тільки в ХІ столітті прийшло християнство.
Ми зараз у печері,
якій близько 4000 років.
Як заходимо в неї,
кожен з нас мусить пригнутися,
бо починає вже черкати головою,
а то навіть і впиратися.
Це явно підтверджує невідповідність
зросту людини 1000 років тому — теперішній.
Кажуть мені: «Не був я і не бачив,
що в Києво-Печерській лаврі Ілля Муромець
має зріст аж 1,57 метра».
Люди були широкоплечі та низенькими,
і тому кожен із тих, хто тут мешкав у той час,
не мав можливості зробити собі так,
щоб кожного разу бити головою, це перше.
А друге — лежанки, могили.
Вони явно коротенькі, не відповідають
теперішньому зросту [людини].
Але це пласт історії,
пласт духовності.
От тут є ікони різних релігій.
Сьогодні це пам'ятка національного значення,
яка виконує єдину функцію:
не ділити людей за конфесійною ознакою,
дозволяти всім ходити.
Тому що це відвідуване туристами місце,
і не тільки з України [туристи].
Знаєте, саме ця унікальність,
духовність цих печер тягне багатьох людей.
Ніякої охорони ви тут не бачите,
місце функціонує —
жодної державної підтримки.
Місце живе,
бо тут і енергетика потужна.
Я втратив свою Батьківщину,
і водночас на базі моєї Батьківщини
утворилося найкраще місце України.
Тобто, чи це є плюс, чи мінус —
от як його розділить.
Хто, звичайно, не жив у цих долинах,
тому здається, що це добре-гарно.
Але зважаючи на те, яке там було життя,
можу сказати:
не гірше, ніж сьогодні.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Андрій Сачева, Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]